Ukrainian medical professionals are
becoming some of the most skilled and
knowledgeable in combat medicine the
expertise however comes at a price when
we work on a wound and in operation room
we just concentrate it and do what we
must do after work with and thinking
about different stuff
then we have a sad emotions but now we
must do and to keep calm Dr ihor loshkin
is good at keeping calm Global News was
granted access to a military Hospital in
the Kiev region and observed the
traumatologist working to repair a
fractured tibia it's a it's a not a big
injury actually shrapnel wounds limbs
torn apart by mines organs damaged by
bullets staff here have seen it all
the staff in this facility say they are
working around the clock if they have a
couple of minutes they sit down get some
food and then they're back at it
foreign
s were simultaneously underway when we
were on site nurses and medical staff
ping-ponged from Supply rooms into the
operating areas Direction shouted and
different songs could be heard coming
from small speakers a well-choreographed
dance in a small space it's very great
honest to uh use my knowledge of help
our guys
most of the patients here are Ukrainian
Soldiers with catastrophic injuries but
there are also doctors injured while
working near the front lines we were
told the man who was rushed past our
camera on the stretcher is a doctor who
lost both legs we're not revealing the
location of this facility or showing any
identifying markers too often they've
become targets the World Health
Organization verified more than one
thousand attacks on Health Care
Facilities since Russia's full invasion
began some days Dr loshkin performs 10
operations other days he tackles just
one complex case we can do one surgery
from 8 AM to
5 a.m all day all night here so you just
you just keep going
away from the busy or we meet Stephan
barabash he's here getting follow-up
care for his back and arm after spending
weeks in a different hospital in the
southeast
the 47 year old was injured during a
mortar attack in Buck moot the location
of one of the longest and bloodiest
battles of the war
it's especially scary at night during
shelling he says they use incendiary
shells everything glows and there's a
feeling that you are in Hell everything
everywhere Burns
for most who end up here the priority is
returning to the battlefield not rest
and Recovery the Medical Teams stitching
them back together are working for the
benefit of their patient but also their
country
Bristol convincing global news keep
region Ukraine